après deux semaines de peur et
d'angoissé la vie reprend ses droits 5-2
vivent en quête de normalité
des enfants jouent tout près d'une
oeuvre d'art dans un parc public tout
près de là une mère de famille
immortalise cette journée radieuse un
portrait à conserver précieusement
choc des générations une intense partie
d'échecs oppose la sagesse du champion
de ce parc à la fougue d'un jeune perdu
dans ses réflexions et stratégies
quelques coins de rue plus loin des
clients retournent ou restaurants de
plus en plus de commerces fonctionnent
normalement elles vivent
linda et diana erre dans la ville aucune
destination en tête que la vague
intention de faire quelques courses et
de se retrouver bouffée d'air frais dans
un monde oppressant
dans le parc loubet ses deux filles
retrouvent d'autres membres de la
famille elles sont arrivées dire pin il
ya quelques jours elles iront visiter le
frère de l'ubo à l'hôpital de lviv plus
tard
militaire au front à kherson il a reçu
des balles dans le dos blessures graves
mais pas mortelle dans un monde de peur
et de douleur
l'insouciance touchante de nas tonia est
désarmante
elles adorent ils vivent pour son grand
magasin de chocolat et de caramel la
guerre semble si loin quand on a dix ans
mais ne révélait pas son âge c'est un
secret
ailleurs en ville un petit marché aux
puces improvisé reprend vie parmi les
flâneurs et rania qui ne lâche pas la
main de son pavla il vient d'acheter un
recueil de nouvelles classiques russes
des histoires d'amour
les entendent profiter de chaque
parcelle de normalité même s'ils sont
rongés par la culpabilité d'être en
sécurité contrairement à plusieurs
connaissances les arrive de kiev et ils
ne savent pas où ils iront dans les
prochains jours
les sirènes d'alarmé ont raids aériens
viennent troubler cette résilience c'est
un autre rappel de la guerre après le
bombardement d'une base militaire près
de lviv
au delà liberté pied-de-nez à
l'envahisseur russe la musique porteuse
d'espoir résonne partout où elles vivent
la population on a besoin
vive villes refuges et importantes bases
humanitaires internationales demeurent
en sûreté un sentiment de sécurité qui
est cependant fragile et c'est philippe
leblanc radio canada vivent en ukraine